maria vorontsova et katrina tikhonova ce
sont les nouvelles cibles des sanctions
américaines infligé à la russie a sont
âgés d'une trentaine d'années sont issus
du mariage de vladimir poutine avec
lioudmila poutina l'objectif visé
directement les comptes des filles de
vladimir poutine qui leur servirait de
prête noms pour cacher une partie de sa
fortune le trésor américain a donc
décidé de saisir tout ce qu'elle
possédait y compris leur ville alors
yacht ou encore leurs oeuvres d'art
vladimir poutine lui-même avait déjà été
sanctionné de cette façon l'objectif
désormais c'est qu'il ne puisse pas les
contourner via ses filles ces sanctions
pourrait rendre la dîmière poutine fou
de rage certains pointent du doigt la
non responsabilité de ses filles dans
cette bière alors faut-il condamner les
vies de vladimir poutine pour les actes
de l'enfer
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
c'est vrai que c'est un bon débat
christophe rento merci entrepreneurs
montée et demi de poutine vous êtes déjà
venu nous voir vous êtes où le dis
souvent la cinquième personne à abattre
alors on en rigole mais sur la liste de
vladimir poutine et bertrand cholet en
consultant en stratégie et vous bertrand
scholler vous êtes souvent présenté
comme pro russe
voilà c'est normal on va voir d'accord
on voit ce que c'est anormal que les
filles de vladimir poutine 60 à moi je
trouve ça totalement normal oui d'une
part effectivement elles sont riches
c'est exact mais elles sont riches parce
qu'elles se sont bien mariés et ce sont
toutes les deux en fait de grandes
professionnelles donc l'une est médecin
l'autre et scientifique l oms sont
chacun à la tête de sociétés qui
réussissent bien dans laquelle il ya des
investissements et les sanctionner en
fait ça touche pas du tout vladimir
poutine en fait ça donne juste une image
de la manière avec laquelle notre monde
qui est le monde de la vérité le monde
du bien en fait est capable de
sanctionner le monde du mal et en fait
moi j'aurais plutôt envie de comparer sa
ce qui se passe avec assange en fait
c'est un message qui est passé à toutes
les personnes qui oserait en fait
s'opposer
à un espèce de diktat qui est nôtre un
français américains et c'est de penser
vraiment symptomatique de cette manière
de taper sous la ceinture de taper à
chaque fois en fait en pensant qu'on va
faire mal et et poutine en fait qu'il a
toujours profit protéger sa famille donc
en fait elles sont très peu connus
elles sont nées l'une en allemagne de
l'est à l'autre à 100 il a deux firent
une maria von sauve à 36 ans et katrina
tikhonova 35 ans elles sont issus de
mariages de valdimir poutine avec
ludmilla poutine a dans le président
russe a divorcé l'aîné comme vous l'avez
dit endocrinologue pour les enfants et
l'autre est spécialiste en sciences
mécaniques y travaille au conseil
scientifique de l'université d'état de
moscou elles sont très discrètes sur
leur vie et très peu de l'image
d'al existe et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui est-ce que condamner les
fils van hemert poutine ça vous dérange
guillaume genton de sa norme non moi moi
moi je trouve ça c'est qu'il faut pas
les noms je pense qu'il faut pas les
condamner je pense qu'en fait on a un
traitement médiatique de ce conflit qui
est très simple en fait on nous dit
voilà faut pas s'attaquer capote il faut
condamner tout ce qui est russe donc la
famille de poutine les rues ses états
voilà donc déjà je trouve ça
complètement débile et je pense que
c'est résumer ce compliqué bien plus
complexe qu'on ne le croit et ensuite
comme l'a dit monsieur ça n'aura aucune
conséquence je pense qu'ils s'en fichent
complètement donc en ça je trouve que
c'est bête et j'aimerais qu'on soit un
peu plus subtile sur le traitement ce
conflit et j'ai l'impression que les
médias nous disent voilà les russes et
des méchants les ukrainiens y voit là et
ça va mais c'est vrai et ça ne sert à
rien violences la police présents pour
lesquels on s'attaque au fid poutine
c'est qu'on imagine qu'elles peuvent
servir de prête-nom région importante
pour la fortune de poutine etc ainsi il
échapperait aux sanctions économiques
sur lesquelles on essaye de le coincer
ces les raisons pour lesquelles on
s'attaquait pas parce que c'est les
filles de poutine ou parce qu'elles
seraient russe
béatrice alors si c'est le cas s'il ya
des soupçons il faut une enquête on est
dans les démocraties dans des états de
droit on ne peut pas agir voilà comme ce
qu'on lui reproche à lui ensuite je
trouve extrêmement dangereux de
condamner des gens parce qu'il ya ils
ont le même adn ben quoi on voit si on
rentre là dedans on va condamner les
gens parce qu'ils sont les le le père
les parents on partage le même adn mais
cela m'a donc assez catastrophique et on
sais pas peut-être qu'elle n'approuve
pas les héros des contes le nombre
d'enfants de benjamin castaldi
et non seulement l'adn mais il s'est
passé quelque chose de très grave en
plus dans une marque très prestigieuse
française qui interdit aux russes
d'acheter pour plus de 300 euros et sa
famille est-ce que je peux le dire
chanel à belfort en france en france et
à l'international
marge des traditionnelles berrebi or et
j'ai une amie qui influencent euse par
exemple elle est en séance aux russes
elle a fait une vidéo où elle elle
découpe et son sac chanel parce qu'elle
trouve injuste que les tous les reçoit
non mais c'était aller à la 9 millions
de followers enfin voilà non mais il n'y
a pas de raison on discrimine pas les
gens pour leur adn ou pour leurs
horizons que technique voilà c'est tout
en mêlant alors s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais qu'on entende berthou
bertrand l'a entendu christophe colomb
de christophe qu'est christophe vous est
ce que vous comprenez qu'on s'attaque
aux figues d'admir poutine
moi ce que je pense c'est que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il ya une certaine
solidarité dans la forme de pensée chez
les poutines parce que en tout cas moi
j'ai pas entendu les filles de vladimir
poutine s'assure g contre le
comportement de leur père sur ce qui se
passe en ukraine et ailleurs donc à
partir de là je ne dis pas qu'il faut
les condamner ou que ceux ci ou de ça je
dis qu'en attendant à partir du moment
où elles n'ont pas dit sur un plateau de
télé sur une radio autre chose au
condamne ce qui se passe si quatre
fortes chances qu'elle soit d'accord
avec leur père bon on est bien obligé de
se dire que va rien dire ça ne
sera pas le droit d en arriver musique
nature 26 et son père sa riche et
naturel ne peuvent pas aller sur un
plateau en russie et commencer à être
comptable impossible c'est qu'on ferait
masse avec un criminel pédophile on
dirait pas à ses enfants de deux
publiquement un savon à mon père la
semaine dernière il m'a fait un switch
harris at on voulait la mayonnaise j'ai
fermé ma gueule
j'ai rien dit dernier gm et harris asba
grave donc tu moi tu vois moi mon père
oui on l'a vu se débat avec les
délinquants et les criminels faut-il
sanctionner les familles tout le monde
répondait non vous dites oui c'est
pourquoi ça n'a rien à voir
mais la guerre est là apparemment elles
ont elles sont médecins jean rieux
donner du monsieur
203 mètres et une villa 2 1 milliards
mais alors c'est apparemment on
construit à des rumeurs qui disent que
tu as ou des 63 ans il
serait armé s'est derechef parlez-lui
mesure milliards de roupies
l'international la dernière chose mais
je pense aussi qu'on cherche le moyen de
déstabiliser poutine parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a aucun moyen de le
déstabiliser c'est à dire que alors les
robinets sont fermés un parent et
poutine y en a pas eu ou sur les deux
qui bougera bertrand est ce que de
toucher au fil ça faisait un peu
déstabilisé pouvoir bertrand si
important ce qu'il faut revenir aux
faits manifestement vous n'avez pas
regardé en fait l'une des filles de
vladimir poutine était la femme du
patron de renault f1 très grosse boîte
pétrolière finalement il a rencontré à
londres une jeune mannequin il l'a
quittée elle a reçu 600 millions lors du
divorce mais comme d'autres femmes de
milliardaires et c'est pas de la faute
de son père et d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez qu'il a ni tué son mari ni
empoisonné ni quoi que ce soit donc pour
une dictature ensuite vous dit tout
c'est une dictature la russie mais il ya
deux mois il y avait facebook il y avait
twitté heures il y avait tous les
réseaux sociaux sur les télés on pouvait
que c'est moi finir à contrôler sur
l'était pas du tout sur les télés on
pouvait interdire sit in vous savez
c'est ici et c'est une des seules
émissions c'est pour ça que je suis venu
vous offrez la parole à des gens qui
comme moi vont essayer de se
s'interroger entre guillemets sur ce qui
se passe dans l'immédiat dans les télés
sur les champs de bataille et c'est
évidemment pas pouvoir faire tout ça ce
matin et ce soir on viendrait et mais la
réalité c'est qu'en ce moment sur les
chaînes nationales russes il ya des
vrais débats comme ici il ya des mais si
vous allez souffrir les traders là aussi
non comment l'ambassadeur russe en sont
à l'école pour la dernière fois en
russie vous êtes à l'écran là bas et en
italie il était avec moi qu'est ce que
vous avez observé semaine par des
copains enfin vous savez très bien qu'il
ya aucune n'y a aucune transparence
s'est très c'est très joli mais vous
savez très bien que tout est sous
contrôle
les gagnants sont des formules comme en
formule tout les styles
donald o o en russie les isles est pas
glisser
vous vous comprenez vous voulez dire
quelque chose il ya un instant à
bertrand qui est avec nous moi je
voulais répondre tout simplement sur la
liberté de la presse
j'imagine que bertrand s'est déplacé de
nombreuses fois en russie qu'il connaît
le média d'opposition qui novaïa gazeta
moi je me suis rendu enfin je suis rendu
j'ai des amis que ce soit en dur dans
ses bureaux et j'ai déjà mis
journalistes que j'ai vu très récemment
et on ne peut voir on peut voir dans
leurs bureaux avant toute chose un
certain nombre de rubans noirs de gens
de journalistes qui sont décédées parce
qu'ils ont ouvert leur gueule moi c'est
pas ce que j'appelle la liberté de la
presse ça c'est une chose la deuxième
chose bertrand
moi j'ai été mis en accusation
par des services russes qui ont fait des
vidéos où j'apparais des images on les a
prises jones et zou et ou pour lesquels
on dit en 2018 j'ai abattu trois
journalistes russes en centrafrique
s'est pas abattue passé et journalise
opposition j'aurais bien aimé les
entendre au contraire pourtant je suis
sur trois vidéos qui ont été vu par 5
millions de personnes sur lesquelles je
suis celui qui a assassiné ses
journalistes c'est ce qu'on appelle la
liberté de la presse est pas ce qu on
appelle la manipulation et concernant
bout de chatons courant bien évidemment
de ce qui s'est passé j'aimerais savoir
si vous condamnez ou non ce qui s'est
passé si vous pensez ce sont les
ukrainiens qui ont manipulé le sujet où
c'est véritablement les russes qui ont
abattu le massacre et butcher il ya eu
aussi l'ambassadeur de russie qui a
fuité
fait voilà
il veut dire passer des comédiens que
tout est manipulé qu'est ce que vous
répondez à sa juste se revenir en arabe
s'il a dit beaucoup de choses donc d'une
part si vous avez été vu par 5 millions
de personnes qui vous accusent d'avoir
tué trois journalistes que vous êtes sur
un plateau pas du tout inquiétés par
personne vous balader dans la rue sans
services de sécurité etc c'est que vous
savez très bien que les russes ne sont
pas des gens qui assassine entre
guillemets leurs ennemis je pense que
vous êtes quantité moi je suis désolé ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est
concernant butch âgées pas d'opinion à
voir sur ce sujet c'est terrible il ya
des gens qui sont morts et ça c'est une
catastrophe pour ans mais les ukrainiens
deux russes ou non les ciels concernant
centric c'est à dire les circonstances
et mais vous savez s'il vous plaît à
redon que vous le condamnez quand même
le tweet de l'ambassadeur russe qui
parle de tournage nominé mais aussi non
vous savez
vous répondre simplement on découvre ou
semaines non mais c'est bien mais c'est
de la folie de pas condamner 28 mai
alors mais
laissez nous
laissez le parler nicolas pernikoff tue
pas du tout agressif y mettra les
libercourtois donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé l'ambassadeur russe certainement
pas du tout au courant dans ses services
une grande ambassade mais laissez moi
parler c'est ce qu'affirme interrompre
avant que je m'exprime joggeuse il ya un
tweet qui est passé avec une image ils
ont essayé malheureusement de faire de
l'humour comme ça c'est
ce que je suis en train de dire qu'ils
ont peut-être voulu faire de l'humour
très drôle et se devaient leur être
intelligent pourtant avant vous avez
l'air d'être intelligent c'est
surprenant vous donner tel problème mais
vous êtes caricatural enfin je suis un
peu caricatural abandonné des bars et
quand même rendre l'expérience est ce
que ma mère d'aller symboliquement moi
d'essayer de me caricaturer mais non
c'est vous qui caractérise une
qu'attendu dit aujourd'hui on n'en
faisaient pas les ennemis en russie mais
vous plaisantez ou quoi et alexis
navalni il est où là c'est juste un
copain qui conte a empoisonné la
braderie en prison de parcours l'année
par le système judiciaire russe et tous
ces gens là réponse non merci
l'humour c'est de l'humour non mais
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est très
malheureux c'est un amalgame maladroit
et c'est n'importe quoi non ils sont pas
faits
s'était fait face
on sait que c'est une mise en scène
ukrainienne vous avez forcément un avis
puisque vous êtes très renseigné à
aucun avis d'avoir une enquête donc
nourri les diar des avis vous avez pas
d'aller vous représentez pas vraiment en
fait attendez que je comprends pas très
bien la fois rude pour représenter
poutine vous représentez gc j'essaie de
poser des questions il ya plus de
questions aujourd'hui les réponses vous
savez monsieur monsieur au cours des 75
dernières années il ya eu des événements
dans le monde qui s'appelle hiroshima
nagasaki
vous voulez une longue liste de moment
où laurent gbagbo est d'accord d'accord
on parle d'ailleurs justement parfois il
faut attendre un peu pour que la réalité
se fasse sur des événements qui sont
évidemment catastrophique parce que là
on est tous confortablement aux choses
sur un plateau mais il ya des millions
d'ukrainiens qui soutient il ya des
millions d'ukrainiens son nom il ya de
plus en plus de russes très bientôt de
france et sur notre monde qui règne en
guinée c'est votre faute si vous pensiez
du navire et il faut des cols existe pas
c'est la même chose
[Musique]
plaisanterie peut-être
poser la question effectivement vous
décortiquez les choses avec avec calme
et tu sais mais ça fait ça fait froid
dans le dos d'ailleurs ça fait prendre
l'eau parce que on n'est pas très loin
de dire que finalement c'est un espèce
de vaudeville qui a mal tourné un crs en
ukraine et moi ça me dérange ça me
dérange fortement parce que vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que je n'avais pas été
menacée comme un certain nombre de gens
quand on vous met la pression parce que
j'ai été menacé quand on veut on vous
met la pression c'est pas nécessairement
pour vous tuer
c'est simplement pour vous empêcher de
l'ouvrir quelquefois ça mais ça
j'imagine donc connaît ça
[Rires]
une chose est certaine c'est
qu'aujourd'hui du complotisme on n'est
pas loin de passion révisionnisme oui
moi je dis que ce qui s'est passé si
demain on nous prouve effectivement
parce qu'ils font peut-être être prudent
mais il ya de fortes chances - chez
aujourd'hui des gens qui me disent sur
place des gens qui ont travaillé pour
moi que ça s'est passé de telle et telle
manière que ces gens étaient abattus
dans la rue par des forces russes c'est
demain il est prouvé que c'est le cas où
mais votre discours mais quel est ce
qu'on en attendait attendait mon propos
c'est précisément ces messieurs vous
avez lionisme devant tous les gagnants
mais non mais c'est n'importe quoi mais
ça c'est la tarte à la crème à chaque
fois que quelqu'un s'exprime en
opposition avec l'idée dominante c'est
un résident et de 90 ch et un antisémite
et settat mais c'est n'importe quoi a
peur d'y laisser une manière messi mais
c'est la prochaine étape ans à les
valoriser l'image que si tout à l'heure
vous avez évoqué et les camps n'existe
pas et c mais c'est tellement facile ça
s'appelle le point godwin et c'est une
manière de tuer les débats de mettre des
étiquettes sur les personnes moi je suis
quelqu'un qui suit argumenté qui
m'intéresse au fait vous savez on vit
dans un pays de droit ici et dans un
pays de droit on laisse parler chaque
partie alors si vous êtes argumenté donc
vous avez une réponse à cette question
que tout le monde se pose mais je ne
suis ni juge ni témoin il ya des gens
qui vont se faire les dents quéven agly
forum des conclusions pâle donne un avis
datant mélanger une conviction et j'ai
couru j'ai pas envie d'avoir un avis sur
un sujet qui est aussi chaud aujourd'hui
j'ai un avis en revanche puisque cela a
été vérifié ce été validé sur les
prisonniers de guerre russes qui se font
chouchouter devant les caméras
ça s'appelle un crime et les enfants
nous intéresse
vous dépassez les bornes avec votre avis
devient ou m'excuser mois là les
ukrainiens ont maintenant identifier
celui qu'on appelle le boucher de butch
à quelqu'un qui aurait ordonné qui a
ordonné j'enlève le conditionnel qui a
ordonné le massacre de civils il ya des
sommes assez drôle on le sait très bien
il est identifié et là vous êtes en
train de remettre ça en question n'a
vous réécrivez l'histoire d'une manière
tour au russe et complémentaires
andalouse mais ces noms étant non
l'histoire elle est devant nous mais
vous vous la contester et si vous
contestez les frères en nous mais est-ce
qu'un petit c'est l'histoire d'un
massacre à bout de charme monsieur que
vous contestez réfugiés 1er au 7 mai il
y aura 4 5 millions de réfugiés cesse
mais il ya des personnes qui sont des
faits cette invasion
est ce qu'on peut donner la vie en
octobre en octobre vladimir poutine à
moscou annoncée à tout le monde qu'il y
avait une citation une situation qui
approchait la ligne rouge pour son pays
d'accord il a dit ça il a dit on
approche de la ligne rouge je suis prêt
à discuter avec vous mais il va falloir
que les choses changent en ukraine six
mois il va décider pour assurer
souverain mais c'est la dame est mais
pourquoi il doit décider pour un pays
souverain mais non mais pourquoi
l'ukraine n'a pas droit de décider pour
elles de son avenir pourquoi les poutine
qui doit décider pour l'équipe ne pas
décider pour l'avenir de l'espèce il
envahit mais non il est il est
effectivement rentré en guerre wallaby
pourquoi il y était et il n'y a pas du
tout décidé d'envahir et d'y rester
d'ailleurs il ya des discussions de paix
qui sont entrés vous a demandé pourquoi
une envie pourquoi ils l'ont mais il à
dire mais il a dit très clairement est
dit là il a dit qu'il voulait demander
nazifié l'ukraine qui voulait la dre nul
donc vous légitimé l'intervention russe
en ukraine mais je ne légitime pas la
tâche aux russes je réponds à une
question qui est pourquoi il est donc il
faut écouter il a des raisons d'y être
nommé sauf que la saison 2 des nazifié
la série dont vous savez que je sais que
dire des raisons qui sont les siennes je
ne sais pas mais je suis en guerre merci
et craignant ni avec erreur